oh mein gott oh mein gott ich muss schon
motor dann kommt jemand da kommt da
kommt
servus s kids und alle zuschauer von
logo herzlich willkommen zur ersten
folge von minecraft legend und es geht
gleich los hier sind hier gerade am
spot- und wir sind alle mega aufgeregt
das wird richtig richtig spannend auf
jeden fall und ihr könnt jetzt schon mal
entscheiden welchen namen unser team
haben soll momentan steht zur diskussion
logo zockt es co uk
und vielleicht war der farbe pink noch
logo wir machen jetzt das projekt alter
der countdown gestartet
okay ich bin heute der plan ist die
folgen hätte ich wohl die melonen das
gelände dort hinter huff das fällt nun
die weizen dinger und laufen richtung
mühle aber dass beide in die mitte gehen
bist du sicher da nehme ich die oben
rechts die an der ecke dort okay ich
nehme die unten links
ich bin wie mein gott ich würde ich sie
auch künftig 15 sekunden
ok also okay bei den die miete ich unten
links du oben rechts und der leute
wünsche euch viel spaß beim flashen es
geht los
oh gott oh gott oh gott oh gott ich bin
einer kiste ich habe nur müll nur mit
habt ihr geld es laufen auch darauf
zurück dass in scheint es irgendwas
enchanted ist gezogen lauf läuft habe
ich entscheide das jetzt geht es nicht
mehr die million zu und ich weiß nicht
ich riskiert nicht folgen wir sind auch
andere sind andere aber erstmal grace
prima weil ich hole die weizen dinge
sind bahn okay dann können wir uns schon
mal ja otmar issing hinter mir bis
hinter mir ja ich bin hinter die ich bau
dir noch alles ab was oft weg ist ich
habe eine goldfischen 24
okay okay aber mit programmen von
frankreich bis hinter mir
the elder scrolls täter machen ja hab
ich gerade was sich so harmlos mit der
grace period die ist vorbei es gibt
keine grenze es gibt keine auch genau es
gibt keine grace ich habe über uns das
intro-video nicht gesehen
wir müssen weg alter mit verlieren mega
schnell hungermarsch asics mein gott ich
muss schnell beantwortet dann kommt
jemand da kommt
hat nicht immer so wie du warst du ich
hab nicht mehr vorher ich weiß nicht
wann ich es tun habe ich hab mir brot
gemacht dass abbauen und weckte die
platte fertig
die computer stoff also ich hab mal
norbert gekillt irgendwie ja wir haben
dort abgeholt aber der etwas geholt ich
habe line gesteckt all oder oder es
wurde auf mysteriöse weise
aber dafür bin ich da junge ist war so
wichtig dass wir das jetzt gemacht haben
hier eine kurve kurz
laut johannes recker leute festfolge es
okay geil alter nicht feiert das macht
richtig bock läuft wir haben einfach mal
den ersten kombis am hellichten tag aber
was oft kann ich kann ich dich hinten
hatte wieder einmal mit der faust wieder
das bist du nicht ein wenig alles gut
alles michael jackson nicht erwartet das
könnte daran liegen dass wir zur weide
games gewinnst du musst normal laufen ja
sprung gartenarbeiten mitnehmen weil wir
das leder gebraucht du hast du die
allergene nähe ist eine kollegin scrollt
dornen 1 deswegen oder petarden bekommen
jetzt nicht da und dann hab ich noch
weggeklickt alter sehr gut ich hatte
noch ich hab' ich weiß ich das muss ich
mir noch mal angucken ich hatte
vielleicht noch ein herz zwei jahre
junge wie knapp alte aber ich habe
glaube ich was ich habe von dem glaube
ich auch ein zweites kassiert oder so
aber er hat gut geklappt okay dann
machen wir es mal hier sollen aber auch
nicht zu weit raus gehen weil die kuppel
verkleinert sicher und das blöde ist
jetzt wohl im info video gesagt welches
biom in welche richtung liegt und wir
haben also ich hab mir das da sind
blutsauger und sinus interphone laster
weg weg weg dort müssen sie wissen wir
müssen für die sind da vorne die sind da
vorne weg vom auf die gehen mir die
angreifen
ja wo sind die runde dass zunächst
riskant ist so riskant sind die gut sind
die gut oder milch ich habe nicht viel
gesehen ich habe nicht gesehen dass es
nicht das musste ich sie nicht fahren da
vorne noch gerade ich hab's auch aus dem
blick verloren
ok dann ja warte ich mache dann lass mal
denn hier wo wir da unten rein gehen es
sei riskant dazu genaueres kann aber in
die richtung ist auch sauer riskant okay
aber dann bleibt oben und hält ausschau
ich gehe runter und ich baue ja mal
intervalle man den kompletten
hier erstmal ab wichtig ist dass du
ausschau hält ist das wichtigste ist auf
uns keiner überraschen was ist das starb
der grauen wie soll ich starb der grauen
als es vielleicht aus der mitte gezogen
aber vielleicht werke waren noch ob grau
vielleicht nur noch getötet habe er kann
sein und staaten starb die atomwende
items drauf also man kann nach gucken
was man für items bekommt einen könnten
ja gleich macht im moment nachgucken
irgendwann ich war das nicht in der
aufnahme neuen niemals niemals sollte
also leute schreibt auf jeden fall ohne
verbot auch ein gekillt alter junge frau
ich hätte erwartet dass das noch gewinnt
gegen uns zwei leute derart riskiert da
muss auch alleine geradestehen was wir
machen also erstmal stein später ja okay
dann haben wir was ich dort erstmals
stand ihnen ein wärter beschütze bin
gerade vor der holzfäller hallo was ihr
an wänden anja ausschau halten ich hab
mir den start hingelegt muss man ihm ja
was denkt sich kreise die ganze zeit um
die bäume herum ich habe ein eiserner
raymond kommt ich habe eine flanke
passieren dass nichts drin abschaltet
erst einmal diesen frame heavy wandbild
ist doch schön hier bleiben wir sind
direkt neben dem spot
ich habe auch was wäre wenn wir uns
einfach in den spawn einnisten uns oben
auf dem spawn das bei mir gar drei
inseln mit ihrer häuser sind ja dort
riesig stell dir vor wir kämpfen uns
einfach da würde doch niemand daran
denken dass nicht du landesname ein
bisschen zwei namen unter unterirdisch
hier unterirdisch ja aber mein wirken
wir wollen jetzt ein echtes kino beim
steinfurter diesen und werte
wir bauen uns herunter zu sehen nein das
schafft man nicht ich habe mir echt
nicht die kommen hochgekommen auch die
kamera fressen
bestes bis 22 aber die namen nicht
davonkommen so die stadt
am 1
jetzt leute ihr habt vielleicht einer
beschreibung vom trailer gesehen
das system ist das folgende jedes thema
dreileben jemand jedes mal wenn einer
stirbt verliert das team ein leben und
viele leute können
respawn sogar das team mehr als 0 leben
hat und mit jedem kill verdient man sich
für das team ein halbes leben das heißt
wer jetzt schon vier leben so also wir
haben für meine inkompetenz haben wir
schon mal was raus kommt erstmal die
ganzen weizenfelder abfahren ganz
ehrlich wir haben wir so viel raum
passen aber die haben wir schon
auseinander gehen die warmwasser und
dann weg
die hatte dieses mal ist es war wirklich
so dass sie gelegt hat und dann werde
ich habe auch gerade eine richtig
schlechte leitung und es ist es hat sich
einfach ausgeglichen aber ich hab
einfach weg gelegt ich habe mega viel
kohle heute seine mega viel kohle
ich habe mega viel kohle also echt ja
erst mal schnell fahren aber hellwach
bleiben denn ihr könnt überall leute
seien
ich habe irgendwie kein game sound leute
aber das ist es nicht so dramatisch ist
das musst du hochstellen das haben die
in dem motto pack untergestellt also
muss erstmal unser video option kann
sich sehr schnell bestellen hat die
rallye team hast du eine zeit im
blickwinkel ja also meine aufnahme werde
bei 4 angefangen urlaub nehmen jetzt
abgewiesen
wir machen die folgen immer so 15
minuten wir können sagen für fast sagen
auch mit den kürzesten dem ihr könnt
diese zehn minuten machen oder ihr
entscheidet hat je nachdem was ihr wollt
und wenn ja auch nie im endeffekt habe
facebook man nicht mehr sind nur so
können können wir uns überlegen schreibt
seine kommentare was ihr davon haltet
und hatte ich es noch ein schwein wo
bist du bist du bist du bist in meiner
nähe dafür ich laufe von junge mit so
viel weizen frank ok warte ich habe ich
hab ein halb sechs ich sollte mal
wirklich jetzt ein haus im spot kommt
einer römerin jemand gesehen eigentlich
gar keiner
ich bin ich stehe ja hier kommt ja alles
ab gerne kann man mit lass mal da oben
in seinem haus und platz suchen models
hingehen ein junge das ist so
offensichtlich nicht im haus warte ich
glaube dass mal drohte
ich habe auch so viel ich machte alles
klar also ich habe 30 boote
das sollte erstmal reichen wir spielen
hier übrigens nicht auf fahrt vor
sondern auf normen oder sohn kim jong il
aber alles gemordet bedeutet wir haben
einmal wieder drin das eigens
geschrieben wurde für diese für diese
sache hier
und ach du scheiße ich vertex voll wir
müssen doch unterirdisch gehen
wir müssen wir müssen uns doch eisen
holen und alles junge kommt komm her
die also ja ja wir haben das mal da
lokal verscheucht aber ich weiß garnicht
bringt da du kannst über pvp keine
ahnung auf jeden fall hatten wir schon
mal
also ich hab mit kassiert auf jeden fall
in dem kollegen ich hab auch ich habe
das sehr seltsam ich lief bergab
einfach in der luft gerade der server
lag noch ein kleines bisschen bin sicher
das wird besser aber das ging das
eigentlich voll klar ist es hat es
geschehen nicht behindert und lass mir
überlegen wir suchen ein spot wo wir
untergehen können bleibt hinter mir blog
direkt hinter mir her ich bin direkt
hinter der dichter bitte direkten ja
okay ist ich konnte ja okay ein kleines
bisschen lag trotz klammer schaufeln
aber nicht mit dem stapel grauen sondern
dann ist das deine schaufel ich hab
genug fertig ich hab ja ganz viele bäume
gefällt mach das erste mal hier unten
die hatten informationen wir übernehmen
einfach den spot übernehmen und leute
übrigens man darf nicht die folgende
anderen schauen darauf steht die
höchststrafe also ausschluss aus dem
projekt nicht wer die folgende
angeschaut und sich das nachweisen lässt
weile als ich irgendwie seltsam verhält
der wird vom projekt ausgeschlossen
haben ok gil ich als alter dann fange
ich direkt an die kohle abzubauen
ja mach ich hab da bei der feuerwehr
feuer gemacht dann siehst du 8 vorne
geht ja auch haus sie sind ja aber
aufpassen
du bist ja nebenbei leute ich höre
gerade tastatur geräusch ist aber nicht
ein ich bin glaube ich im zweiten
teamspeak noch online.de manchmal dicht
hier so alles klar jetzt geht es besser
stell mal kurz eine fackel auf hier
steht steht man auch gucken wie wir wo
wir gelandet sind
die haben sie schon versucht runter zu
bauen aber dann nahmen sie unseren namen
gesehen
ja und dann haben wir direkt aber die
hat noch die situation so zu sagen haben
dann hast du doch jetzt das schwert oder
karierte kein schwert doch da bin ich
lag bei 108 nicht einfach so ich bin
auch ein apple da will ich einfach
gerade mal ein bisschen stein ab da
werde ich meine stärken kläre ich hab
ich mal kurz draussen um 8 fackeln aber
passt auf was auf dich auf oben
naja ich gucke mich nur ob ihr was kommt
dann machen wir immer weiter halt
ausgehobene also wenn ich jetzt eine
frist überrascht bin ich einfach du
kannst ich war nicht überrascht werden
im endeffekt gibt es nur diesen einen
eingang aber die konstatiert rheinbahn
aber das müsste dir aufwand ein bisschen
werbung freuen
ich komme ja von hier ganz kurz hier
geht noch ins wasser und wenn wir das
bambus zu viel
ich bin ich habe fünf schritte gemacht
hätte hätte ich sicher den kommentiert
zu vorsichtig wm hat in der ersten folge
schon acht kates gemacht hat gar kein
hehl gemacht als hauptspeise und ich
weiß nicht ob kein gesehen okay ist ein
natürlicher höhle
ich habe natürlich höhle gefunden hast
du mal noch drei stein für mich dann
könnte ich mir ja auf jeden fall ich
hab' ich habe eine natürliche höhle und
hier ist richtig viel eisen
hier ist richtig viel eisen wir gehen
dahin wir gehen dahin ja hier ist mega
viel reisen wollte wo ich runter bin ja
ja ich weiß wo du runter gegangen ist
was wir sind schon voller entrüstung
jaja der folie alles ab da oben alles ab
ja ich habe keine geht nicht hat keine
stein spitzhacke ich brauche drei steine
arbeite ich dann komm ich hoch ihr
segelt man einfach geht mir einfach ein
bisschen steine läuft das ab ob ich dann
kann das geld gar nicht mitnehmen
hier da ist ein pickel für dich da danke
dann brauch ich das oben ab was du dir
schon gelernt nein habe ich nicht habe
er nicht bekommen
um nicht nico rosberg ok lilo also nee
das auch schon dauern
ich habe man hat ja drei leben oder habe
ich das richtig verstehe schon klar da
hast du das alles jetzt aufgehoben ja
wir haben dann hat man hat nicht drei
leben ich habe ihm erklärt also es ist
unterschiedlich hängt davon ab wie der
teampartner spielt das ganze thema darf
dreimal sterben ich bin ich dumm alter
einfachste kräften so ja aber da du ja
besser bist glaube ich eher dass ich
sterbe wird sich zeigen könig mit
ankündigung mit ankündigungen aber wenn
wir da oben nicht über die fakten
ausmachen macht ja weg ich habe mir kurz
auf das eisen kohle was ihr habt hier
zeigen die gäste die in ihren reihen
oder machen wir ja aber eigentlich muss
man mit kleinster und zu machen aber
egal wie egal jetzt ist auch ein blatt
wie ist es dahin gekommen da machen wir
sind jetzt schon bei 14 minuten ist man
gleich aufhören
ich hab die aufnahmezeit nicht ganz
genau aber lassen hier noch bisschen
eisen abbauen
ja ich fahre mir gerade noch etwas geht
natürlich okay dann haben wir auf jeden
fall nächste folge schon mal privat über
oh mein gott der hat ja nur ein
heimliches abgezogen alter immer blocken
wenn du wenn du so wenn du so naja ich
hab jetzt noch geblockt sehr sogar
robert ist es für mich alles alles gute
alles gute nachricht hat mich heute ja
sterne dem projekt machst du mich fertig
ich ach quatsch nein aber als richtiger
adrenalinschock habe gutes equipment ihr
also es gibt sicher andere die schneller
waren
aber wir haben interessieren wo da luca
dir zu schnelles reisen er hatte das
eisenhaltige gibt garantiert andere die
1000 mal schneller waren aber wissen
team uk oder esco oder hitze oder der
halter oder logo zeigt wie ihr wollt
auf jeden fall geben wir unser bestes
hier für euch
logisches kecskemet ist als es ist okay
und dann machen wir jetzt einfach mal
schluss hier würde ich sagen ja komm
hier drüben hier drüben an die erde
können wir uns sicher einbauen ohne dass
es auffällt
hier kommen wir waren natürlich ehrt
aber da fällt das nicht
okay leute der ersten folge minecraft
wegfallen lassen like da ich jetzt mir
gut gefallen schön viele kills für euch
hoffentlich was unterhaltsam check logo
haben jetzt in der beschreibung ganz
oben in beeskow und dann lasst eindeutig
nach oben